e
[Música]
y
hablar de lo que no se habla puede
cambiar el mundo
piensa en la primera vez que hablaron de
sexualidad
la primera vez que aprendieron a
entender su cuerpo la primera vez que
supieron reconocer que les gustaba y que
no
quien les enseñó cómo dónde de que
hablaron y de qué no hablaron
porque es que
vivir nuestra sexualidad
se aprende con nosotros mismos y con
otras personas conocer entender y cuidar
nuestro cuerpo se aprende y así como se
aprende se enseña y se enseña hablando
pero también callando
hay barreras invisibles que no nos
permiten hablar
sobre sexualidad sobre sexo sobre
menstruación sobre el cuerpo sobre
derechos
que nos censuran y que nos silencian y
que nos amenazan con pecado y con
perversión y con vergüenza y con culpa
no hablar tiene un costo muy alto
en el pueblo de barú al sur de cartagena
en la isla de barú en colombia
fui profesora durante dos años este
lugar es un lugar abrazado por manglares
por un lugar que no tiene acueducto ni
agua potable y la única institución que
hay es el colegio ahí eras profesora de
inglés y de sociales y noté que mis
estudiantes muchas faltaban al colegio
cuando tienen la menstruación y que
decían que no podían hacer muchas cosas
o ir a ciertos lugares cuando tenía la
menstruación
pasa que en colombia uno de cada cuatro
niños en comunidades vulnerables no va
al colegio cuando está menstruando eso
es casi tres meses al año que faltan al
colegio
y eso tiene que ver con que el 45 por
ciento de las mujeres han manifestado
que no conocen lo básico sobre su ciclo
menstrual que les pasa todos los meses
de eso no se habla
mi segunda semana como profesora me tocó
ir a la casa del estudiante entregarle
unos talleres porque acababa de parir
ella tenía 15 años en su casa de otras
dos mujeres menores de 18 años y cinco
hijos una de ellas aprovecho mi visita
para preguntarme sobre la tarea de su
hijo ella no sabría leer no había
terminado el colegio
en colombia aún el 17.4 por ciento de
los embarazos son de mujeres menores de
19 años y dos de cada cinco embarazos no
son deseados de eso no se habla
uno de mis estudiantes más juiciosos de
3º una clase no se quería sentar y no se
quería sentar porque le dolía y le dolía
porque la noche anterior había sido
violada
el 70 por ciento de las mujeres han
sufrido algún tipo de violencia y de eso
aún no se habla
eso es la educación sexual aula
pero a pesar de que en colombia desde
1993 es obligatorio que los colegios
haya educación sexual pues más allá do
porque a pesar de los miles de planes de
gobierno y programas de db de nacionales
y cartillas para implementar la
educación sexual únicamente el 17 por
ciento de los colegios ha logrado
implementar un proyecto de educación
sexual
nosotros nacemos como seres sexuados
pero no sabemos cómo hacerlo eso lo
aprendemos y hemos relegado la educación
sexual a películas a memes al reggaetón
a una charla incómoda con el abuelo o
con la tía con el privado con la mamá o
experiencias propias que pueden salirnos
muy caras
como el colegio no me permitió hablar de
esto decidí invitar a mis estudiantes en
barú a un espacio extracurricular en una
casa comunitaria para hablar primero
sobre ministración primero haremos 7
después 10 después 15 y ellas me dijeron
que cuando nos volvemos a encontrar y me
exigieron seguir encontrándonos para
seguir hablando
en estos espacios con sentábamos en
círculo en el piso y nos mirábamos a los
ojos para hablar sobre nuestro cuerpo
para hablar sobre placer sobre amor
sobre nuestros miedos sobre nuestras
confusiones para desmitificar por
ejemplo las siete telitas de la
virginidad o que en efecto la puntica
nomás si puede premiar hablábamos de
interrupción voluntaria el embarazo
y hablábamos juntas
para descubrir el poder de decisión que
tenemos sobre nuestro cuerpo nuestra
sexualidad de nuestra vida ella se
autonombraron las barreras poderosas
y decidieron que ese poder que tenían
ellas que solo se los daba la educación
y que no se los quitaba a nadie tenían
que replicarlo a más poderosas en otras
comunidades así que se volvieron
lideresas y siguieron haciendo estos
encuentros en otros lugares
eso se convirtió en un movimiento
imparable que cada vez está llegando más
partes y siguiendo hablando sobre estos
temas
qué pasaría
si habláramos más
incluso en pandemia ellos se dieron
cuenta que la verdadera pandemia eran
los embarazos no deseados y que no se
estaban cumpliendo los derechos sexuales
y reproductivos de su comunidad así que
ellas mismas gestionaron y movilizaron
brigadas para dar anticonceptivos y
varias opciones de anticonceptivos a las
mujeres de su comunidad
hablar cambió la vida de estas jóvenes
la de su familia y la de su comunidad
para siempre en 2018 hubo 18 embarazos
en bachillerato de barú y en 2019 fueron
qué tal si hablamos
qué tal si hablamos con nuestros papás
con estos no más con nuestras abuelas
con nuestros hijos con estos con nuestra
pareja con nuestros amigos que está si
hablamos de eso que no hablamos que no
hablamos y por qué no hablamos
no hay que ser profesor para ser
educador en educación sexual
hablemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]